I'm instantly regretting my decision
I am bleaching my armpit hair so it
doesn't hurt but it's a little spicy
oh man this is gonna get all over me
laughs it looks like a tennis ball
I'm just marinated in blue dye maybe
some people do it because it's funny I'm
doing it cuz it's funny well maybe some
are doing it as a statement about
standards of female beauty the dyed
armpit look is sort of a way of saying
it's my body it's like you don't like
women with ollinfit hair let me take it
one step farther let me put some neon
colors on this mother blow it in your
face if you feel secure in your body
you're not worried about what people
think then why not try it do I put my
armpits no I do not put my armpits
I've had these my entire life I grew my
armpits I just keep them manageable I
don't grew my armpits I mean I put on
deodorant but these babies just kind of
take care of themselves
just looks ridiculous my armpits look
like the head of a troll doll the more I
see it the funnier it gets I definitely
feel like I'm from the capital of The
Hunger Games
there's nothing I could do to fix this
does anyone know how long it takes to
grow armpit hair cuz I sure don't what
if this takes ten years going to
Catalina Island tomorrow with my
girlfriend's parents and they're gonna
be like oh who's this freak having this
kind of makes me feel like if I had a
tattoo in a naughty place am i doing
this for other people no I'm doing it
for myself and it feels pretty good
Oh